have i ever had on passant meet
uh i don't think so if i did i would
have remembered it
i've been close maybe a couple times but
it's really hard to orchestrate
okay so on the streak let's berserk
again a pre-movie five this time
ah my pawn so this is called the walrus
it can potentially transpose to stafford
if white plays e4
if i play g3 i'll play um h5 h4
and white has different options here but
i have i have nice open
things for my pieces
yeah the walrus it's an animal but it's
also a dubious gambit
um now white's playing really safely
which is probably a good strategy
i'm going to play aggressively i'm
already thinking about greek gifting
why he just needs to castle jake
when are you playing fog of war again
well it has to be foggy outside
there is a few weeks ago i took a
picture in st
louis a fog
let me find it
yeah this one it was really foggy in st
louis
i even said it was it was a good day for
fog of war
but today can i show
where's my picture
so i took this i took another picture
today about an hour ago
look at this i guess it's still
technically kind of fog but it was also
kind of snow
um so
yeah the king was getting getting snowed
on
i play this move bishop b4 c3
i have bishop f4 too can a fancy move
probably not a great move
the thing is i don't want to trade
pieces
oh am i losing pieces
queen f3 i had g5 maybe okay so the
bishop did some
dance and now it's here
i'm potentially losing another pawn or
not
okay i want to go for this move now
actually this is kind of a annoying
thing
okay
yeah this would have been really
uncomfortable i probably would have had
to take on c2 and then pray
but this is exactly what i wanted
apart from the fact my bishop is weird
i'd really love to like sock on h2
[Music]
um
i guess i'll start
start with this i'm provoking queen here
i'll probably play like bishop c8s
or maybe something more aggressive queen
g5
now let's be safe
if i get to play b6 and the queen is a
bit weird
oh i have an idea rook d5 rook d5 rook
g5
have to be careful here
calculating this queen b4 line
jake's takes i think it's okay i'm
allowing the fork but i'll have this
move
ooh okay here i can take
i think i'm winning a piece now
also thank you maha roberto and emc 42
oh and muckaluck
something about stafford and the s
oh yeah the ass my middle name is
stafford
uh unless it's not
um have this move
um pieces are weirdly out of play
i think i just want to like kick white
away from
being annoying this move
okay so preventing a6
that's still kind of uncomfortable
i might play c f n c five
and c5 is the move i want to play
in this move first i'm creating the
battery on the
fifth rank
yeah i think i'll just play this just
for safety
and maybe undouble my pawns
because now it's harder for white to
attack
okay now we're going to simplify i was
writing mate there as well
[Music]
okay this is a double attack
soon to be mate
or not um
[Music]
oh there's on passant oh it's gonna be
on passant mates i think
on passant checkmate oh please play c4
don't resign come on yes on poisson
checkmate
who was it it was xy sparks earlier
mentioning asking if i've ever had on
personal checkmate
this is my first on poisson checkmate
i feel so accomplished it's one of those
like bucket list items that's
you don't know if you'll ever accomplish
in life
but now i feel so accomplished
wow so this is what it feels like
it's just like a huge burst of joy
i have to prevent myself from crying
tears of happiness
hi youtube yeah chad is going wild
i need to make an on croissant emote now
but for now we have the high youtube
emote thank you t games
this is slow mode too chad is going so
fast hi to kimmy shout out to kimmy and
thanks
coop jack smith
what a game that's a fun game
slow motion replay
slow motion
and that will probably be the finish the
video
thank you meatballs